you spent so much time falling on the  campaign that you noticed you started to  notice things about specific things  about Trump like you have specific  observations about his mouth that you  found kind of fascinating it's got two  positions for his mouth uh-huh  one is a perfect oval and words are just  projected out of it he does yeah yeah oh  and then just like he's blowing a horn  shoots words he just blows and words  come out and he probably like a kazoo  has no control over which words they are  your observation not mine yeah I do I do  talk about his vocabulary looking like  an aerial version of a freight train  crash yeah yeah just mangled nothing  makes sense right and then the other  version is just a smile that completely  cuts his face in half mm-hmm kind of  like I I envision the South Park  Canadians Canadians and South  [Applause]  you